the prospect of a meeting between the US
and Iranian presidents was an unlikely
outcome with the g7 in Barretts but as
the summit came to an end its host the
French president suggested talks between
Donald Trump and Hassan rouhani were
possible at some point there has to be a
meeting between the iranian president
and the US president I hope that in the
next few weeks this meeting will take
place France plays a role along with the
other partners who sign the Iran deal
Trump who pulled the u.s. out of the
2015 Iran nuclear deal last year and
impose sanctions said he was open to
diplomacy we're looking for no nuclear
weapons no ballistic missiles and a
longer period of time very simple we can
have it done in a very short period of
time and I really believe that Iran can
be a great nation I'd like to see that
happen the development came one day
after the unexpected arrival of the
Iranian Foreign Minister in Biarritz
javad zarif was invited by the French
president had been asked by some g7
leaders to mediate in the crisis
Trump's conciliatory tone was also
extended to trade
he said Beijing and Washington could
begin talks to resolve their tariffs
dispute going into this summit Emmanuel
macron said he wanted to use it to make
progress on the escalating tensions over
Iran and trade helped tackle the Amazon
rain forest fires and he'll divisions
using multilateral cooperation at the
end of the three-day meeting it seems
that French president has succeeded on
several fronts there were unresolved
issues though the UK's Prime Minister
Boris Johnson received only a vague
promise of a future trade accord with
the US and was no nearer to a deal on
brexit with the European Union I think
that it's the job of everybody in
Parliament to get this thing done I
think it's what the people want I also
think by the way it's what our friends
and partners on the other side of the
channel want they want they want this
thing done they want they want it over
last year Trump refused to sign the
final g7 statement this year Macra has
scrapped it replacing it with a one-page
summary of the meeting so
with no commitments in writing the
challenge will be to compel leaders to
act on the verbal promises they have
made natasha butler al jazeera spirits